like maybe we should have a third just
to you know have more kids
two years later body Prince lose
introducing baby number three to the
world it's really special for me the
model shared a first Glimpse at her
third child with husband Adam Levine on
Sunday the pick comes in a series of
Instagram snaps from Maroon 5's first
week of their Las Vegas residency
[Music]
his band and his music like still keeps
him busy the band's Big Show comes after
the couple made their first public
appearance at the Vanity Fair Oscar
party earlier this month since news
broke of Adam's cheating scandal last
fall see I think at the core of it we're
truly just we're truly best friends you
know and we we really get each other on
a on a deeper level so
when there's a lot going on and and he's
on tour and I'm busy and the kids and
stuff we always
we have so much fun together that we
always want to be together so we make
that happen I think we've
we've set a pretty high standard for us
as a couple individual the two of us
aside from the kids and family and all
of that to really just make sure we're
good and one if we're good the kids are
good our families are good so we're just
a good team I don't know what it is
there the pair welcomed their new bundle
of joy in January but has yet to share a
name or a gender I always knew I wanted
more than one because I'm an only child
the newborn joins six-year-old Dusty
Rose and five-year-old Geo Grace he just
is so good with them they love him so
much we were born to be a parent
that's what we're here for really yeah
all the other is great but it's not what
we're here for we have like dance
parties at the house
after dinner
and it's only Maroon 5 and Adam would
sit there and say can we please just
listen to something else for one dance
party and they're like now Lucky Strike
they're singing it like She Will Be
Loved in this love and and Sunday
morning it definitely gets gets his
heart strings going and and he I think
can't believe what's happening
um there is times that they fight
throughout all the songs and he's like
turn it off I can't listen to myself
sing anymore while they scream over it
yeah the kiddos are big fans of their
dad's hits and seems they'll hear lots
more as Maroon 5 continues their
residency at Dolby live in Las Vegas and
I used to be out here for me and now I'm
not here for them and then everything
all the medicine in the whole world
foreign